>> Sean: EARLIER TODAY
HILLARY CLINTON HAS THE
AUDACITY OF ACCUSING
PRESIDENT TRUMP IGNORING
SECURITY THREAT POSED BY
RUSSIA.
THE FAILED CANDIDATE WARNING
THE RUSSIANS ARE COMING.
NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGIST
SEBASTIAN GORKA, NATIONALLY
SIPPED INDICATED RADIO TALK
SHOW HOST LARRY ELDER.
DR. GORKA, WHERE DO I BEGIN,
DOSSIER, URANIUM ONE, OR THE
RESET?
>> LOOK, YOU HAVE TO LAUGH
BECAUSE OTHERWISE YOU GET
REALLY, REALLY ANGRY.
THERE IS NO OTHER SECRETARY
OF STATE THAT THIS NATION
HAS EVER HAD SINCE 1776 THAT
HAS DONE MORE DAMAGE TO THIS
COUNTRY FROM URANIUM ONE TO
FISA GATE TO THE FACT THAT
SHE HAD A SERVER THAT WAS
ILLEGAL, THAT HAD TSSCIAP
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ON IT
THAT U.S. OFFICIALS HAVE
SAID IS ABSOLUTELY HACKABLE
BY NATION STATES, INCLUDING
RUSSIA.
I REALLY, REALLY THINK THAT
THIS WOMAN NEEDS TO GET OFF
SOCIAL MEDIA, GET OFF
TWITTER, AND FIND A LAWYER
WHO IS BETTER THAN THE
LAWYER SHE USED TO BUY THAT
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA TO GET
THAT ILLEGAL SURVEILLANCE
WARRANT AGAINST CARTER PAGE.
>> Sean: LARRY?
>> WELL, SEAN, AS BETWEEN
RUSSIAN MEDDLING AND THE
CORROSIVE EFFECT OF OUR LEFT
WING MEDIA, THE LEFT WING
MEDIA HATS A LOT MORE TO
ANSWER TO.
THERE WAS AN EXPERIMENT DONE
BY A PROFESSOR WHO WROTE A
BOOK CALLED LEFT TURN.
HE WANTED TO FIND OUT WHAT
KIND OF EFFECT THE LEFT WING
MEDIA HAD HAD ON PEOPLE WHO
VOTE.
PEOPLE WHO NEVER GOT "THE
WASHINGTON TIMES"
CONSERVATIVE NEWSPAPER WERE
OFFERED SUBSCRIPTION TO "THE
WASHINGTON POST" AND LIBERAL
NEWSPAPER AND VISA VERSA
THOSE OFFERED A NEWSPAPER
OFFERED TO THE CONSERVATIVE
NEWSPAPER AND FIND OUT HOW
THIS EFFECTS HOW PEOPLE
VOTE.
AND IN BOTH CASES PEOPLE
SHIFTED.
THE PEOPLE THAT GOT THE
LIBERAL NEWSPAPER STARTED
VOTING SOMEWHAT MORE
LIBERALLY.
THE PEOPLE THAT GOT "THE
WASHINGTON TIMES," THE
CONSERVATIVE NEWSPAPER
STARTED VOTING A LOT MORE
CONSERVATIVELY.
HE CONCLUDED THAT IF PEOPLE
REALLY GOT THEIR NEWS IN A
FAIR AND BALANCED WAY HALF
LIBERAL, HALF CONSERVATIVE,
THE AVERAGE STATE WOULD VOTE
THE WAY TEXAS DOES WHICH IS
8 TO 10 POINTS IN FAVOR OF
REPUBLICANS.
THAT IS A CORROSIVE EFFECT
OF OUR LEFT WHIPPING MEDIA
FAR MORE DAMAGING THAN ANY
KIND OF RUTION MEDDLING.
IN THE INDICTMENT OF THE 13
RUSSIANS THE CONCLUSION WAS
THE MEDDLING HAD NO EFFECT
ON OUR ELECTORATE.
IMAGINE THE EFFECT OF OUR
ELECTORATE OF OUR LEFT WING
MEDIA, FAR MORE CORROSIVE
AND POWERFUL AND DAMAGING.
>> Sean: SUCH A GOOD POINT.
DR. GORKA, RESPOND TO THAT
WHEN YOU THINK THAT ALL THAT
THEY IGNORE, IT IS SO
PROFOUND IN HOW THEY COVER
FOR THEIR IDEOLOGY AND IT'S
SO PERVASIVE.
>> JUST LOOK AT THE LAST 13
MONTHS, SEAN.
WHAT HAS THIS PRESIDENT DONE
WITH REGARDS TO RUSSIA?
HE IS ALLEGED TO BE IN THE
POCKET OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
BUT WHAT HAS HE DONE WITH
THE UNLEASHING OF OIL
PRODUCTION IN ANWR.
THE XL PIPELINE.
THE FRACKING.
IS HE DESTROYING RUSSIA'S
STRANGLEHOLD ON GAS AND OIL
WITH NATO FINALLY AFTER 30
YEARS SAYING OKAY, WE'RE
GOING TO PAY FOR OUR OWN
DEFENSE AND MEET THOSE 2%
G.D.P. TARGETS.
HE HAS BROUGHT THE ALLIANCE
BACK TOGETHER.
BY SAYING WE ARE GOING TO
ARM THE UKRAINIANS, HE IS
DOING THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
HILLARY AND OBAMA DID WHO
ROLLED OVER, ROLLED OVER
WHEN RUSSIA INVADED THE
UKRAINE.
>> Sean: LARRY, THE FINAL
WORD.
>> DON'T FORGET HOW THEY
THREW THE CZECH REPUBLIC AND
THE POLLS UNDER THE BUS
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T LIKE THE
DEFENSE DEEM NEGOTIATED.
DON'T FORGET ABOUT ALL OF
THOSE THINGS THEY DID.
TRUMP IS CONSIDERED TOO COZY